Welcome, curious minds to
another deep dive.
Great to be diving in again.
Today we're plunging into a
truly provocative idea, one that
actually started with a comment
I saw online, buried deep in the
usual digital noise.
Oh.
Yeah, what was it?
It was stark surprising and just
said the quiet thing out loud.
Well, technically, Trump really
is a God.
Wow.
OK, that's, that's a statement.
And before anyone jumps to
conclusions, let's be absolutely
clear right from the start,
please, you The intriguing
source material we're exploring
today is not talking about a God
of worship, you know, hymns or
incense.
This isn't about traditional
religious devotion or like
offering sacrifices on an altar
or anything like that.
Exactly.
It's about a God in a much more
primal, raw, and, well, literal
sense, the way the ancient
Greeks, maybe the Hebrews or
desert nomads understood.
It OK, so like raw power?
Think of an all powerful father
figure who, with just a flick of
the wrist, could smite a
village, flood your fields, or
simply wipe an entire camp off
the map.
That kind of unchallengeable,
fearsome power.
Right.
The kind you don't argue with.
It's about the sheer,
overwhelming might that can
reshape lives and landscapes,
almost like a force of nature
embodied in a person.
Our mission today, then, is to
unpack this extraordinary idea,
drawing heavily from a truly
thought provoking source titled
Zeus the Trump How America's
Godless Made a Thunder God out
of a Mortal Clown.
Quite a title.
It really is, Yeah.
And this text offers a
fascinating lens through which
to view contemporary power
dynamics.
It's, well, it's quite
something.
OK, let's unpack this.
We're going to explore how this
perception, this almost mythic
status seems to have taken root
in the modern age, what it
reveals about the nature of
power itself today and the
intricate psychological
mechanisms, you know, the stuff
going on in people's heads that
are at play within society.
And a crucial point to emphasize
here, really crucial this is an
impartial exploration of the
source materials ideas.
It's not an endorsement of any
political viewpoint whatsoever.
Our goal is simply to convey the
fascinating, often unsettling,
and deeply insightful
observations contained within
this particular text.
That's it.
So get ready to see power and
Perception in, well, a truly
different light.
This source really flips things
around.
It does.
So to truly grasp the profound
inversion that Zeus the Trump
presents, our source first
directs us to its literary
insiration.
Garrison Keller's short story
EUS the Lutheran.
Ah, Keeler, right?
This is where the foundation for
our Dee dive begins, and his
work gets really interesting.
Keeler, you know, with his
characteristic wit.
Imagine the ancient Thunder God
Zeus himself somehow slipping
into the rather dumpy,
unassuming body of a
Pennsylvania pastor.
Yeah, I remember that one
vaguely.
What's absolutely fascinating
here is the sheer absurdity and
almost like tragicomic nature of
the premise.
Totally.
Zeus, the mighty king of the
gods, right?
Known for his earth shattering
thunderbolts, his immense power
and his rather notorious history
of many dalliances, Yes suddenly
finds himself confined to what
the story describes as this
flappy mortal suit just.
Stuck and his original, rather
undignified divine purpose in
this new form to seduce a mortal
housewife.
Of course, classic Zeus, even in
a cheap suit.
And to achieve this, he
unceremoniously and quite
humorously shoves the pastor's
actual bewildered soul into the
body of a dog.
Poof into the dog.
It's brilliant in a dark way,
right?
It's a perfect setup for cosmic
humiliation, isn't it?
Imagine this incredibly powerful
cosmic entity, the very
embodiment of divine authority,
suddenly stuck in the utterly
mundane, suffocating routine of
suburban life.
Yeah, dealing with bake sales
and, I don't know, parish
council meetings.
Exactly.
He discovers just how utterly
unfitting, how frankly demeaning
it is to be worshipped in a
language that doesn't resonate
with his ancient grandeur, or to
navigate the petty, perplexing
realities of modern existence.
The central joke, as our source
points out, is this petulant,
perpetually horny, immensely
powerful Greek God who once
ruled Olympus.
Now trapped in a parochial
suburban parish, he still
carries that lingering aura,
fear from his past, that vague
sense of his former might.
But he's not quite powerful
enough to truly bend the world
to his divine will anymore.
It's also petty.
So sad.
And ironically, in its
confinement, it feels very, very
human.
The true comedy, or perhaps the
tragedy, lies in the stripping
away of his cosmic agency.
He's just and.
This sets the essential stage
for the profound inversion
explored in Zeus the Trump,
because while Keeler's fable is
about a God shrinking himself
right diminishing his divine
essence to fit into a human
form.
Right, becoming less.
The material we're examining
argues that the modern story is
precisely the opposite.
It's a decidedly mortal being
who is elevated, or perhaps more
accurately demonized into a God
like figure by the very forces
arrayed against him.
That's the core.
Flip the precise inversion of
the fable.
Instead of a God sneaking into
an unwilling pastor, our modern
Storm God, as the source vividly
describes it, lumbered down an
escalator, orange and grinning.
That image is seared into
memory, isn't it?
It is.
And from that pivotal moment,
according to this analysis, a
significant portion of the
country, particularly those who
perceived him as an adversary,
began a collective, almost
subconscious transformation of
him.
He became the scapegoat for
every hurricane, every plague,
every bad harvest, every secret
dread that the sky still wants
blood.
Wow, so projecting all anxieties
onto him.
It's an almost anthropological
observation about how we
attribute vast, uncontrollable
forces to a singular figure,
like we need someone to blame
for the chaos.
This naturally raises a critical
question.
How does a Federer described as
thoroughly mortal someone the
source depicts as you know,
petty, flawed, combed over,
clumsy?
Yeah.
Very human descriptions.
How does that person become this
formidable bunker busting Zeus
in the collective consciousness
of his detractors?
It seems like such a leap.
It does.
The material posits that in the
heads of his enemies, he didn't
just become a political
opponent, he evolved into the
trickster who grew thunderbolts,
the Primal Father God who
devours the field when the
lentil's not marked.
That's some heavy mythology
being invoked there.
The Trickster, The devouring
Father God.
Exactly.
It's an astonishing leap of
perception, transforming a human
into essentially a force of
nature in their minds.
And here's the crucial
difference from Keller Zeus, a
distinction our source stresses
as Paramount.
Kaler Zeus eventually faces some
kind of cosmic reckoning, right?
There's mention of a cosmic
lawyer coming to drag him back
to the mountain, returning him
to his proper, albeit chastened,
place.
Orders restored.
He's put back in his box.
But for Zeus, the Trump, the
source argues there's no such
thing because, and this is the
key phrase, they keep the fire
burning.
They his enemies, yes.
His enemies, by feeding him
their dread, their constant
unyielding focus, their fear,
their outrage, inadvertently
keep him immortal, in this
perceived sense anyway.
So the attention itself empowers
the image.
That's the argument.
They keep him alive and potent
right here in the modern
suburbs, floating like a storm
cloud over every podcast and
every bedtime panic scroll.
That's chilling, the idea that
negative attention feeds the
very thing you fear.
It's a chilling and fascinating
idea of how collective human
attention, even negative
attention and fear, can
inadvertently imbue a figure
with profound, almost mythic
power, sustaining A perception
that transcends mere political
reality.
The fear becomes the fuel.
It keeps the Zeus's persona
alive in the public mind.
Exactly.
So if we shift our focus from
perception to practical reality
for a moment, what does this all
mean for the real world
implications of power?
Good question.
Our source highlights a crucial,
often overlooked point.
People frequently underestimate,
or maybe just forget how much
real concrete power the modern
American presidency actually
carry.
Yeah.
We talk about checks and
balances, but.
But this isn't just about
abstract perception or, you
know, how people feel about the
president.
It's about the tangible tools
and immense authority that have
systematically accumulated,
particularly since a pivotal
moment in recent history.
That's a critical distinction
the source draws.
It emphasizes that especially
since 2001, since the towers
fell, there's been a collective,
almost unspoken agreement across
the political spectrum to break
the locks on the executive
branch.
Right.
The Patriot Act era.
The expansion of surveillance.
Exactly this vast expansion of
power was, according to the
source, justified in the name of
safety, in the name of eternal
war, and in the name of
permanent surveillance.
Think about the incredible,
almost unimaginable array of
tools that have been placed at
the disposal of this modern
Zeus.
It's not just symbolic power
then.
Not at all.
It's a monumental shift in the
balance of power, concentrating
immense authority in one office.
When you connect this to the
broader picture, the sheer scale
of this executive power is truly
immense.
The material we're examining
details of vast drone fleet at
the president's command, capable
of striking anywhere on the
globe with precision.
Right, the power to wage war
almost unilaterally.
Then there's $800 billion a year
in open defense spending alone,
a number that's almost too large
to fully comprehend.
Vine boggling sums.
But then, as the source starkly
adds, there are trillions more
tucked away in black budgets and
shell contracts and off books
cyber OPS.
The stuff nobody sees.
These are the shadowy
expenditures, the untraceable
operations that operate beyond
public oversight, granting
unparalleled covert
capabilities.
It's staggering when you
consider the totality.
And it's not just money or
drones.
We're talking about over 80
known military bases
strategically positioned around
the world.
But as the source chillingly
says, who knows how many more?
In the shadows, in the air,
under the sea.
These are the hidden outposts of
an expansive global military
footprint.
So the implication is stark and
direct.
This figure with these tools
possesses the chilling ability
to snuff out how many little
sparks with a nod of a head or
the swipe of a Sharpie on an
executive order at 3:00 in the
morning.
That's real, immediate,
overwhelming power capable of
altering lives and even nations
of the mere directive.
It embodies a kind of modern
technological omnipotence.
Now the source takes us to a
specific hypothetical point in
time, painting a vivid picture
of a potential future scenario.
Here we are, 168 days into a
second term.
Trump the 47th.
OK, setting the scene for this
hypothetical second term.
It sketches out a vision of a
presidency that, in this
imagined second term, has
achieved significant, almost
unprecedented victories,
consolidating power in a way
that fundamentally reshapes the
political landscape.
Oh, absolutely.
According to this compelling
scenario in the source, he
secured the swing States and
even the popular vote, which, as
the source notes, they said
could never happen.
Great.
Defying expectations again.
And then there's the Electoral
College landslide, which, as the
source Riley puts it, made all
the Pearl clutching, say,
democracy types RIP their hair
out while the normies just
poured another cup of gas
station coffee and said, well,
it's done.
A very cynical take on public
reaction there.
It is beyond that in this
hypothetical, he has the House,
he has the Senate, at least
until the midterms.
So unified government control.
And the Supreme Court is
described as locked down tighter
than Fort Knox, every big ruling
slicing his way like the storm
got himself nudging the scales.
It's a vision of unchecked,
overwhelming political
dominance.
This imagined scenario contrasts
sharply with the challenges
described in his initial term.
Right.
The source pointedly notes that
this time around, he didn't come
in blind and surrounded by
Vipers like his first rodeo.
No more Brutus at his shoulder.
Implying he learned from the
first term purged the disloyal.
That's the suggestion.
The preparation for this
hypothetical second term is
described as absolutely critical
and meticulously planned.
The material suggests he spent
four years in the political
wilderness, brooding like an
exiled king.
Like Napoleon on Elba or
something.
Kind of running endless scenario
drills the way JSOC Joint
Special Operations Command
builds plywood cities in the
desert to practice the perfect
raid.
This implies A strategic, almost
military like precision to his
return.
So not just winging at this
time.
Apparently not in this scenario.
Here's where it gets really
interesting about his
hypothetical preparation
objective.
He didn't just plan, he built
the maps, built the traps, built
the kill switches.
Little switches?
That sounds ominous.
It does.
The objective as described in
the source was fundamentally
different this time around.
He wasn't seeking to make deals,
to compromise or to engage in
traditional political
negotiation.
So what was the goal?
He came back to finish what he
thought was stolen from him the
first time, and he's doing it
before the bureaucratic white
blood cells can even get their
shoes on.
Wow, that's aggressive imagery.
Bureaucratic white blood cells.
It's a depiction of a very
deliberate, calculated and
ruthlessly efficient approach, a
stark contrast to the perceived
chaos and reactive nature of his
first term.
The image is one of a figure who
has learned, adapted and
returned with a singular,
unyielding purpose.
To reshape things permanently,
it sounds.
Like that's the implication if
we connect this phenomenon to
the broader historical context,
The source draws some truly
compelling parallels between
this modern figure and ancient,
seemingly gospel like mortals.
Like Pharaohs and Caesars.
Exactly.
It challenges us to reconsider
how figures of immense power
throughout history attained
their perceived divinity.
Were the Pharaohs, for instance,
truly gods?
The source provocatively asks.
You think the Pharaohs weren't
just men in shiny hats who knew
how to swing a sword and claim
divine blood?
It suggests their divinity was a
construct right, a claim to
legitimacy and power, rather
than an inherent truth built on
force and spectacle.
Precisely.
And then there's the compelling
case of Julius Caesar, who, as
the source eloquently puts it,
was just immortal until the
Senate made him immortal in name
because the crowds needed him to
be bigger than death.
So his deification wasn't a
divine intervention, it was a
societal and political act
driven by collective human need
and aspiration.
People wanted him to be more
than mortal.
That's the argument.
This leads us to a profound core
insight from the source.
Every God in the old stories was
just a man who could kill you if
you crossed him and bless you if
you bent the knee.
Wow, that just strips, well, a
mystical veneer, doesn't it?
It really does.
It brings the concept of divine
power down to the raw,
fundamental mechanics of
dominance, submission and
absolute control over life and
death.
It's a very clear eyed, almost
brutal assessment of what God
like power truly meant then.
And arguably what it means now
for a figure like Trump.
According to this sources
perspective, it's about the
capacity for reward and
punishment on a grand scale.
So with all this in mind, what
does this Thunder God look like
in full unrestrained operation
according to the source?
Well, our source doesn't mince
words or offer any pretense of
benevolence.
It describes him as not even
pretending to be a kind God.
No friendly neighborhood deity
here.
Not at all.
This isn't some gentle guiding
deity who offers solace.
Instead, he's vividly portrayed
as Zeus in full Thunder mode,
roaming the sky, chucking bunker
Busters when the mood hits him,
signing Killis with a grin.
The terrifying image Raw,
unvarnished power exercise
without compunction or mercy,
where the arbitrary whim of the
ruler dictates fate.
What's particularly fascinating
here is how the source employs
specific Stark metaphors to
illustrate this power in action,
and it's far reaching
psychological effects.
OK, like what?
Take for instance the ICE
dolphin trick metaphor.
The ICE dolphin trick.
What does that mean?
OK, so the tuna is presented as
the official publicly stated
excuse for an operation.
For example, rounding up
illegals with ICE raids, rolling
like armored locusts through
communities.
This is the ostensible purpose,
the tangible target that
justifies the action.
Right, the stated reason for the
raids.
But the dolphins, as the source
reveals, are the real meal, the
true objective, or, perhaps more
accurately, the devastating
collateral damage that extends
far beyond the immediate target.
Ah, like dolphins, cotton tuna
Nets the unintended or maybe
intended consequence.
Exactly, the source explains.
The sweeps aren't just about
who's legal and who's not.
They're about putting fear back
in the air.
The real flex, as the source
calls it, is the show of power
that reminds everyone the door
kickers can stand in your living
room at dawn because the Storm
Father says so.
So it's not just about catching
the tuna.
It's not just about the fish.
It's about a broader, more
insidious message.
It's about reminding everyone,
regardless of their own status,
that the net fits over your
whole street.
That's incredibly chilling.
It illustrates how the perceived
power of this Zeus transcends
the immediate target, spreading
A pervasive fear throughout the
community, making everyone feel
vulnerable.
This specific action is a
performance designed to generate
a much wider psychological
impact of obedience and dread.
It's psychological warfare,
essentially.
This leads us, naturally to a
crucial question about
protection and allegiance within
this power dynamic, drawing on a
powerful Old Testament story,
the Passover lentil.
Yes, the blood over the door.
Right.
You'll recall the story of the
Israelites marking their doors
with lamb's blood so that the
Angel of death would pass over
their homes bearing their first
born.
It's a story of divine judgement
and explicit protection.
A.
Very clear marker of who is safe
and who isn't.
And the source applies this
ancient concept directly to the
modern context, with remarkable
insight.
The villagers, which the source
clearly defines as Trump's
ardent supporters, believe they
have explicitly marked their
Lincoln.
Not with actual blood,
presumably.
No, not literal lambs blood, of
course.
In the modern world, it's
symbolized by distinct public
declarations of loyalty and
belonging.
Things like the AR in the
closet, the bumper sticker, the
Sunday potluck, the Don't Tread
on Me flag.
OK, so these are the modern
signs of allegiance.
These are, in the sources view,
clear shorthand for.
I'm inside the covenant.
Zeus will smite someone else.
They believe with profound
conviction that they are
protected, that they will be
passed over from this perceived
wrath because they have declared
their allegiance.
They see themselves as under his
protection.
In stark contrast, the source
describes the 33%, or more
pointedly, the priesthood, which
it characterizes as the rational
coastal pure reason priesthood,
or the secular moral class.
The opposition, basically the
critics.
Yes, they are depicted as having
traded the lentil for an
abstract moral superiority,
believing they can reason with
the Thunder.
They rely on intellectual
arguments, moral righteousness,
logical discourse.
Trying to debate the storm.
Exactly.
But the source is unequivocal in
its assessment of their
approach.
They can't.
Their tools are seen as
insufficient against a force
that doesn't operate by reason
in this view.
So the outcome then becomes
quite stark and binary.
According to this perspective,
you either have the blood over
the door or you don't.
That's it.
It suggests A fundamental,
unyielding choice in the face of
this perceived power, where
intellectual or moral standing
offers no real protection.
It's about affiliation, not
argument.
And what does this God demand
from those under his sway?
Is it praise Worship?
The source clarifies that he's
not asking for praise, he's
demanding obedience, or at least
fear.
Same thing in the end.
Obedience or fear not love or
admiration.
It's not about worship or, you
know, babies on an altar.
None of that.
It's about a primal, undeniable
choice.
Your door marked or your door
smashed.
Chilling.
Return to an ancient absolute
concept of power.
Where loyalty is rewarded and
dissent is met with swift,
overwhelming force.
That's the essence of this Zeus
figure.
Now here's what a source calls
the funniest part, if any of
this is funny at all.
OK, I'm braced.
It's the profound, almost absurd
contradiction inherent in the
perception of his enemies, the
very same people who for years
relentlessly called him an
incompetent clown, poopy pants
dotard shuffling around like a
sedated grandpa.
Right.
The criticisms focused on
incompetence, buffoonery.
Are now, according to the
source, utterly consumed by
portraying him as omnipotent.
They cannot stop talking about
his immense, almost supernatural
power.
That is a contradiction from
clown to omnipotent controller.
This observation raises a
crucial question about the
internal consistency of
narratives, particularly those
fueled by intense opposition.
How does the source illustrate
this?
It uses vivid, almost
caricatured examples.
These same individuals are now
described as portraying him as
pulling the strings in Israel
and Palestine, implying a global
reach and orchestrating complex
geopolitical events.
Assigning him vast international
influence.
They depict him as orchestrating
the world's genocides from a
golf course in Florida,
suggesting a chilling, almost
detached malevolence.
That's quite an accusation.
Further, they see him vanishing
dissenters into black sites and
turning local cops into federal
snitches, conjuring images of an
omnipresent totalitarian
surveillance state.
So attributing near total
control and malevolent intent.
The irony truly is striking,
almost a form of self parity, as
the source so pointedly
observes.
These people say he's a fool,
but they also say he's God.
They don't even hear themselves.
It's a powerful statement about
how fear, political opposition
and constant vilification can
inadvertently, perhaps even
ironically, inflate the
perceived power and efficacy of
an adversary.
And this paradoxical dynamic
leads us to what the source
identifies as the weirdest part.
Something terms the tulpa
effect.
The tulpa effect.
OK, you need to explain that
one.
To understand this, let's define
tulpa.
In Tibetan mysticism, a tulpa is
a thought form, basically an
illusory being or entity
conjured into existence by sheer
mental concentration and
collective belief.
So like willing something into
existence with your mind?
Kind of.
It's an entity made real, or at
least given substantial form by
sustained mental focus.
What's truly fascinating here is
the sources audacious
application of this esoteric
concept to modern political
dynamics.
Does it apply?
It argues that the rational,
coastal, pure reason priesthood,
those who pride themselves on
being immune to superstition or
magic, are in fact doing the old
work everyday, meaning they
believe they are above such
primal forces, yet they are
inadvertently participating in
their creation.
That's the key to profound and
unsettling paradox.
By constantly talking about him,
By fearing him, By endlessly
memeing him, By hate binging on
every piece of content related
to him.
The constant obsession.
By focusing their collective
dread and outrage, they are, in
the sources words, pumping
psychic helium into the
trickster until he rips the
clown suit off and puts on the
Thunder crown.
Wow, so the argument is their
focus creates the powerful image
they fear.
It's an unnerving idea that
negative obsession, ceaseless
attention, and fear can
inadvertently create and empower
the very monster you claim to
despise.
Your constant focus, however
critical, serves as a life force
for the entity you wish to
diminish.
That is deeply counterintuitive,
but it makes a strange kind of
sense in terms of focus and
energy.
And this phenomenon connects to
another profound spiritual
concept, but with a surprising
modern twist, what's often
called the God shaped hole.
The idea that humans need
something transcendent.
Right.
The traditional spiritual idea
is that humans inherently crave
higher meaning or power.
There's a natural, perhaps
innate, human desire for
something transcendent to
explain chaos, loss, and fear.
This void is often referred to
as a God shaped hole in the
human heart, a space meant to be
filled by faith or purpose.
OK, standard concept.
What's the twist?
But the source presents a
fascinating and unsettling twist
on this ancient concept.
This hole has migrated.
It's in the head.
Well, I graded to the head.
Yeah, the dreadless.
They're rent free initially,
perhaps like fleeting bad viral
Jingle you can't get out of your
head.
But now it's metastasized,
growing into an entire cathedral
of anxiety.
A cathedral of anxiety?
That's a powerful phrase.
So it's a secularized,
internalized space for fear and
obsession, constantly being
built and expanded upon by
dwelling on the threat.
Exactly.
It's an incredibly vivid and a
relatable analogy for modern
anxiety.
If you've ever had a panic
spiral at 3:00 AM, the source
compellingly states, you know
how that works.
The monster you keep feeding
never moves out.
Oh yeah, that hits home.
The more you focus on the worry,
the bigger it gets.
It's a powerful way to describe
how constant fear, negative
attention, and the inability to
disengage from a perceived
threat can become a
self-sustaining, self
perpetuating cycle.
The more you feed the fear, the
larger the monster grows in your
mind.
Perpetuating the very entity 1
fears and the psychological
dynamic also brings us to
another compelling metaphor from
folklore, the golem.
The Golem.
Right, The clay, the creature
exactly.
The golem originates from Jewish
folklore, typically a creature
made of clay brought to life
through mystical means, often to
serve and protect a village from
persecution or threats.
A protector figure.
The source masterfully employs
this metaphor to explain the
underlying motivation of Trump's
supporters, whom it refers to as
the villagers.
They didn't necessarily set out
to create a God or a demigod at
first.
What they wanted, the source
argues, was a champion golem, a
QB, a powerful protective
figure.
So not a God, but a fighter, a
shield.
They sought a slab of clay to
yell at the other side and swing
a big foam finger, a symbolic
strongman figure to represent
their frustrations and fight
their battles, allowing them to
go about their daily lives with
a sense of security.
OK, that makes sense as an
initial motivation, but here's
the inherent danger, as the
source points out of any Gollum
of any created entity given
immense power.
It's the danger.
Eventually it believes it's the
spell.
Oh.
It believes it's the spell,
meaning it forgets it was
created and thinks the power is
its own.
It's that chilling moment when
the creature designed to serve
and protect, designed to be a
tool, starts to believe it is
the source of the power itself,
that it possesses inherent
agency.
It gets struck by the lightning
and thinks it's him throwing it,
not the crowd.
Attributing the source of power
incorrectly.
That highlights a profound and
dangerous shift, where a figure
initially empowered by
collective will begins to assume
that power as entirely its own,
becoming an autonomous force
separate from its creators.
And then there's the pervasive
phenomenon the source identifies
as the Wolf Cry syndrome.
The boy who cried wolf,
basically.
Pretty much.
The Wolf Cry syndrome refers to
the persistent, often hyperbolic
warnings that have been issued
for years regarding this figure.
The source notes that they
screamed dictator, literal
fascist Hitler for 10 straight
years, creating a constant
deafening alarm.
Yeah, the rhetoric got very high
very quickly and stayed there.
The rhetoric escalated quickly
and stayed at a fever pitch,
making every perceived threat
sound apocalyptic.
Everything was turned up to 11
all the time.
But the effect of this incessant
crying wolf, this unceasing
barrage of dire warnings, is
profound and, according to the
source, counterproductive.
How so?
Desensitization.
Exactly.
If, despite the alarms, crops
keep growing and the Amazon
boxes keep arriving on time, if
daily life continues without
immediate catastrophic upheaval,
the villagers, the everyday
people, inevitably tune it out.
It just becomes background
noise.
This leads to what the source
calls the normie shrug.
The more the wolf cry echoes,
the less normies care, becoming
desensitized to the warnings.
Eventually, their reaction
shifts from fear to weary
indifference.
And they might even start
thinking the warnings were
overblown from the start.
Right, leading them to say with
a pragmatic cynicism, better
Zeus than locusts.
They prioritize stability and
their personal comfort over the
abstract warnings, perceiving
the Zeus as a lesser evil than
potential societal collapse or
just constant disruption.
The tragedy, as identified by
the source, lies in the rigidity
and predictability of the
priesthood's response.
The priesthood never updated
their script.
Same lines, same signs, same
burn barrel effigies.
So no change in tactics, no
modulation of the alarm.
The repeated, uncalibrated
warnings lose their impact
because they fail to adapt to a
changing psychological
landscape.
There's no nuance, no escalation
beyond what's already been
declared.
And the source concludes this
point starkly and ominously.
The trickster laughs.
Zeus cracks his knuckles.
That suggests A fundamental
failure to understand the
psychology of the populace and
the diminishing returns of
constant exaggerated alarm.
Thereby allowing the perceived
power of the Zeus to grow
unhindered and unchallenged by
effective countermeasures.
The cries become ineffective
noise.
And finally, there is what the
source calls the comedy of
immortality anxiety.
Immortality anxiety.
Who's anxiety?
This delves into a deep seated
psychological Dr., specifically
the priesthood's intense desire
for their own form of
immortality.
Critics again?
How are they seeking
immortality?
They aren't seeking traditional
religious immortality, but
rather a secular, historical
one.
They want their moral arc to be
recorded forever, to be seen as
the ancestors who bravely fought
racism, the courageous souls who
metaphorically stormed Selma, to
be undeniably on the right side
of history.
OK, legacy being remembered
favorably by future generations,
this is.
Profound psychological
observation.
Truly, they yearn for their
grandchildren to look back and
say I was on the right side of
history.
I stood for what was just.
It's a quest for historical
validation and enduring legacy.
Makes sense, but the tragedy as
presented by the source is a
bitter paradox.
Let me guess, back to feeding
Zeus.
You got it.
The same people who say they
hate Zeus spend every waking
hour feeding him their fear,
keeping him immortal.
Their very opposition, their
constant emotional investment,
becomes the lifeblood for the
figure they despise.
That's a truly bitter irony,
isn't it?
While they relentlessly pursue a
form of immortality through
moral arcs and historical
legacies, striving to leave an
indelible mark, they themselves
still turn to dust and worms,
same as always.
As the source bluntly puts it,
they are quite literally feeding
the very thing they despise,
purring their energy and focus
into sustaining its perceived
power.
While their own quest for
lasting moral impact might be
undermined by this constant fear
driven engagement, it's a
fascinating, almost poetic
analysis of human motivation,
it's inherent contradictions and
it's unintended, often self
defeating consequences.
The energy spent in fear could
perhaps be re channeled into
building the legacy they truly
desire.
Is that the underlying point?
That seems to be the
implication.
Where you put your focus matters
immensely.
So if we pull all of these
intricate threads together, the
flipped fable, the real power,
the metaphors, the psychology,
how does Zeus, the Trump,
manifest in our undeniably
modern world?
Well, the source describes him
as the first mortal to wear this
crown in the 4K surveillance
saturated 247 doomscroll age.
Right.
This isn't some ancient figure
shrouded in myth, known only
through whispers or carvings
like Caesar or the Pharaohs.
Exactly.
This is a figure hyper
documented.
Every gesture, every utterance,
every perceived flaw captured in
excruciating detail broadcast
instantaneously across the
globe.
Constant scrutiny.
What's truly fascinating here,
and a core paradox the source
highlights, is that the whole
world sees the mole on his ear
in real time.
And yet it only makes him more
mythical because the
hyperexposed saws make him seem
human.
So when the storm comes, it
feels personal.
Wait, so the flaws make him more
mythical, not less?
How does that work?
The idea is that because he
seems so undeniably human, so
flawed, when he wields this
immense power or is perceived to
be this Zeus figure, the power
feels more real, more immediate,
more personal, not like some
distant abstract deity.
OK, the juxtaposition of the
mundane human and the perceived
immense power makes the power
seem more impactful, more
jarring.
He's uniquely positioned in our
hyper connected age, he's the
first Zeus with a drone fleet,
and a CNN panel devoted 24 hours
a day to parsing every Belgian
tweet for signs of the next
Thunderbolt.
It's an almost absurd yet deeply
revealing combination of ancient
archetypes and cutting edge
technology and media saturation.
Both his believers and his
enemies, as the source
meticulously notes, perform
their fear live.
Their reactions, their
anxieties, their allegiances are
constantly on display,
contributing to the spectacle.
Well, as the source says, the
normies decide if they'll mark
the door or just wait to see
whose house floods.
Just watching the show, trying
to figure out how to stay safe.
It's a live public and constant
drama playing out on a global
stage with very real stakes.
This phenomenon naturally raises
an important question about the
longevity of this storm and the
duration of this perceived
divine power.
How long can this last?
Right.
The source reflects on the
current situation,
hypothetically set in July, a
year and a half until the
midterms.
It describes this figure, this
modern Zeus, riding every lever
like a kid in a junkyard mech
suit.
Great image.
Surrounded by generals and guys
in blue suits who will do
anything to keep the machine
humming, it's an image of
relentless, almost mechanical
exertion of power enabled by a
system and its loyal operators.
So he's Zeus, but only until
he's not.
He's the storm father until the
villagers bench him or the
priesthood runs out of fear to
feed him.
There's an implied fragility, a
dependence on the collective
will or the collective fear.
It's not inherent power forever.
But the source is quick to warn
with a chilling prediction.
But don't bet on that happening
soon.
People need a God.
They need need something to
blame when the flood comes.
That insight implies a deep
seated human need for a
scapegoat, for an external
powerful force to explain and
absorb the chaos and anxieties
of the world.
A need that may transcend
specific political figures.
We might just replace 1 Zeus
with another if the underlying
need isn't addressed.
The source culminates in a truly
chilling warning, painting a
vivid picture of the
consequences for those who
refuse to acknowledge this
conjured Zeus, or maybe for
those who fight him in the wrong
way.
OK, what's the final warning?
It suggests people will stand in
the street door, unmarked,
burning the effigy until the
flames slip their chain and burn
the barn too.
Wow, that depicts A destructive,
self immolating cycle where the
very act of protest and
defiance, untethered from
understanding the dynamics at
play, leads to widespread
indiscriminate destruction.
Bringing down your own house to
spite the storm.
God.
And then comes a final, truly
provocative thought, a direct
and unsparing message from the
source material itself.
If you think this ends clean, if
you think the Angel of Death
only wants the first born, you
haven't been paying attention.
Implying the consequences will
be widespread, not targeted.
Some doors are marked, Some
doors aren't.
The priesthood that pretends
they don't believe in gods is
about to find out the hard way
that when you conjure A Zeus,
the Thunder doesn't care about
your think pieces.
Brutal.
It cares that you kept the fire
burning.
Powerful stuff.
It really brings together the
idea of conjuring power through
fear and the tangible
consequences of that power,
regardless of intellectual
arguments against it.
So what does this all mean for
us then, in the grand scheme of
things?
Taking a step back from this
deep dive.
Well, I think the core insight
from this source material is a
powerful one.
The perception of power,
especially when fueled by
intense fear, constant
attention, and the fundamental
human need to blame.
Which seems deeply ingrained.
It really does all that can
elevate a mortal figure to a
near mythic status akin to an
ancient Thunder God.
It's a fascinating and deeply
sobering look at how collective
human psychology can
inadvertently create, sustain,
and empower the very forces it
fears and claims to oppose.
We build the God we dread.
In a sense, yes, according to
this perspective.
And this exploration leaves us
with a final resonant thought, a
challenge directly from the
source itself.
Let's hear it.
May you mark your lentil, or at
least know who you're feeding
when you scream at the eclipse.
Wow, OK, that's something to sit
with.
It's a profound call for
self-awareness, isn't it?
Urging us to consider the far
reaching implications of how our
attention, our emotions,
particularly fear and outrage,
might inadvertently contribute
to the very forces we wish to
diminish.
Yeah, it forces you to think
about your own role in the
dynamic, whether you intended or
not.
Are you marking your door or are
you feeding the storm with your
screams?
It encourages us to gain a
deeper, more critical
understanding of the complex,
often unseen relationship
between power perception and
collective psychology in our
modern world.
Definitely a lot to chew on
there.
Absolutely a very different way
to look at things.
Thanks for diving deep with us
today.